in this capsule we will see
the iteration algorithm by policy
so we saw previously that exists a
first iteration algorithms by value
to find the optimal plan of a
hearing process brand returns and
now we will see another
iteration algorithm by policy which
unlike iteration by value or
at each iteration updates the
values ​​of the optimal plan we are trying to
find interesting by their politics
at each iteration will change
explicitly the politics we are in
city ​​train but the optimal policy
that we are looking for and so it's going to be a
algorithm that in the same way like
value is very young will find the
optimal policy but whose
unfolding will be different here's
the algorithm so in this case also to
each iteration cpu vector of or a
table of value for a pole and the
implicit policy that have reached by
esteemed as in valeo and regions
who's going to change it's really a
worse politics or a plan we're going
update and we see improved
from one iteration to another so what we
will do what we will initialize a plan
the plane pip rim arbitrarily
random way and there we will repeat
several steps until convergence
enough until we do not succeed
to improve our policy that premium
by a new policy
and when we actually do it is that good
firstly we start by assigning
pipart our current policy which
premium is what we will do is that
for all states as a whole
big s i'm going to calculate what is the
value of the plan worse by solving the
associated equations
to the recursive definition of value
of a plan so here we have the definition
recursive the value of a plan so that's
what we saw before the value
of a plan c a state s this is the
reward in s
the more the discount rate times the
future reward hope but that actually
it's basically a system with
number of states equation that contains
number of states unknown so this is a
linear system that can be solved
with the day m so we solve these
equations let there this gives us all
values ​​vépy two aces for our
policy which is then for all
states in my state set I
will see if he responds new actions
that I could take that would
better than the current action in pi
is actually a way to finish 6th not
better action is to see is this
that for every small state is that
the value associated with seurre that I esteem
is here with my system of equations
linear
is not lower than the
value that I would get if I took
another action
and if I assumed that I already had a
good estimate of my values ​​for
other states and this bonus so more
exactly what I'm going to do is
that for every state is that I'm going to see
what is the associated value that I
just calculate and I'll see what that
it's actually smaller than the
reward in s plus
lotto of this tale once the reward
future hope for another action that
the action pi 2 s
and if there is a better action
according to this criterion there but worse of s
Wife time is associated with this action
otherwise i will keep then premium of s i
I will keep it so that this
either my action pi 2 s i'm not going
switch
the associated action and which I continued
interests like that until no
actions for any of the stoles do not
so change mme hamon
complete plan does not change and at this
moment I'm coming out of my loop here and I
return the policy then or the plan
then let's see an example of a
simulation of the execution of paris six
regions have defined an initial plan that
will be at eze and red at cécile axes
of smell action to the state is this a gesture
also the two-state action and the state is
I associate the action with 4 so it's distri
cipav the color of the sagging
so that I'm going to update the little
graphic according to the policy
or current clan and logitech
so I said who will become then
premium
and here I build my system
of equations so the system of equations
the value in s 0 what is it one
compensates in 06 and 0 plus the factor d
second time the future reward hope
associated with the current action the action
current zero co2 that makes me return
on f zero so that will be increased by 1 of
stay at 0 times the value 0 which the
proven reserves variable 1
the sausage action and where is simple to
relations relations action associates co2
and so we go where the equation booth v1
was gala award to a 5-0 plus the
second time factor with a priority
of a I agree 13-0 that a value
0 then for v2 action 6 to 4 which
pass from 2 es2 to es7
with a parity 1 so I like
equation v2 is equal to 1 since that's
the reward in s2 plus 0.5 times a
weight revised and so it turns out that the
solution to these systems of equations
the acv 0 is equal to zero
v is zero and v2 tigana if I
replaces v0 per hour
is zero then v2 is equal to one
same thing here to do you can
check but actually I have equality
to the left and to the right
so I solved the system of equations
and when I do it later
that I check for each of the states s 0
s1 and s2 if open better actions
so learn the current mans 1 0 I do
the action to both I will see if
action in europe in the best sense i
was doing the action in two
games here at 3 and promises a 15-2 I
did the action at 4 currently know
if at 5-5 6 would not be but so is this
which here is the value associated with
if I took action at 1 and that
I used my values ​​my 0 v1 v2
as the valuation of values
so of the value of the plan so if I
do at 1 from scratch I'm going to have
a reward of zero since 0 the
reward is zero plus the factor d
second time this time 0.2 so if
I'm doing to a young neighbor here I talked
from 0.22 stayed at 11 00 points twice
targeted rookie is equal to zero + 0.8 he
did not have the idea to spend 2 m 01 s as well
bedside the action at 1 times the value
associated with saint who lv1 and v1 was
hardly currently is estimated at 0 so
I have zero here it gives a value of 0 0
it's not bigger than the value that
I had previously estimated for zero
so I have no reason to change
action against if I do it for
the state is healthy
so with the action at 3 instead of jaude
2 I will have a reward of zero
plus the factor and second time one who
the probability if I make 3.2 me returns
at s2 it's proof it's a part
of an airlock think train 2 if I do
the action at 3 so once the value
currently esteem for s2 so there
v2 which is the value associated with s2 and that
currently it is estimated at 1 so I
one here so if I did zero plus zero
point 5 x 1 x 1 it gives me 0.5 ski
strictly larger than 0 which was
the currently estimated value for v1
it's worth to this or full where I
do 1 2 1 1 0 2 1 then in 4.1 s 2 so
I just found that the action at 3 would
better than the action smells 1 and will be
so the action will change I will put
my plan for the state is healthy
for the field
now my new plan is going to take
as action at 3 and if I do
exactly the same but to love
in s2 that I look
would autsai not be a
best action i'm going to get a
1.5 reward estimate at s2
plus the second time factor the
future reward hope based on my
estimate of the values ​​of the rewards
future hope here crime worth future
so that gives me 1.5 which is fatter
that 1 which was the value currently
estimated for my current plan in the state
s2 is so again a s2 I
will have an earlier action at 5
since it seems to be a better
action
given these tests the here and I
go on like this so now the
policy is different in v1 state
next this is your s2 since
now I'm doing the action at 3 so my
system of equations change it if
now I'm going 2.6 up to have
0 as it was the case before then
same thing here before I had one for
the equation associated with themselves
and at gb2 since in front of the action at
the one that is the action I take
now that at choice s 2 I stay s2
so I did two here and if I do
exactly the same test here
I could not improve the actions
in this case also the action that I can
improve his series s 0 I find he
takes 1 will be better than the action
current that was 2 so I'm going
change to 0 but decision it's going to be
take action so my system
of equations changes again we see that
now to aim for the system
of equations have changed since the action
in 0 changed to now we go where 0.2
times life zero because if i do
action to a chimpanzee 0.12 to stay at
0 then 0.8 times the value of the
neurons at s1 from scratch that's
0.86 I do the action and the subject redone
the test so if I compare now if
I took smell instead for s 0 to 2
instead for essen then at 4 at the
place for s2 I observe that it is paul
cox is not the same but the action so
I do not change the action taken for his
three stars so I converge I have
found my plan optima their brands
actually it's the same dish we
had found with a terrace you by
value in the chair capsule
no i'm going to do a reminder about how
solve systems of equations
linear
so we have an example if the system
of linear equations we had at the
last iteration of policemen their
region to solve it
what we do we do what we do
learned to swim come to know that one
can put all the constants to the left
then kept all the variables right
when I did here private jets 0 then
I suck them very right what makes
that I'm going to see so if I 0.5 point
0.2 since in 0 point 1 - 1 then
minus 0.9 as the factor that
multiply the heroes and for v1 it's
just his drummer 0.5 point 0.8 so
0.15 so I do the same thing with
this equation if ai this equation
here I take the variables are at
left the state to his right
and with this system of equations there it is
easy from equation 3 to deduce
the value of v2 it's going to be just
minus 1 / - 0.5 so 2 from
equation 2 but as long as I know the
value of both I can replace here v2
bar its estimated value ie 2 so
I'm going to get that so jean see two
times 0.5 so one and so I'm going to have
punctured one that i can transfer silva
is zero point 5 x 2 so a game
well that some is equal to 1 and
finally the equation I replace here
by a jld rap place there is no d2
reminded those of perfumes 1
I can then deduce that v 0 galas
0.4 pepper and a 10 0 points 9 had a
equal to 1 that's going me 4 out of 9 for
0 so that would be the procedure was getting done
in the hand would be a way to solve
but in what it's actually it's a
system of equations that was pretty
simple but obviously in practice we will
do that with computers so
often we do what we will do is
that we are going to do this writing of our
system of linear equations or to see
we will see here a vector and then
we will actually have our variables all to
right
now he's going to write it under a
matrix form or bva correspond
to the constants vectors here a level
correspondent - 0 0 i will have seen here
that your only it's really
vector of my values ​​for all
states of the zeros v1 v2 and finally I
matrix rebates that will match the
coefficient here on the variables of my
system of equations so in this water
if we would have the first row of
the supply - 0.9 0.4 which multiplied 1.0
which ... me
d2 as if I had zero x v10 here
second line as if I had zero x
had zero since 0 and not in
the equation too - hours here 0.5 here
Institute is raining in the rows 00 - 0.5
it is claimed that I write them under this
form there I will be able to actually call
bookstore that will allow me to
solve the system of equations
linear so for example we could
do it with a similar man in python
so I will create a matrix named straw
because this congress the matrix so first
row here
second row third row that's me
would give the vector raymond matrix
of constants that would be 10 00 -
hours and then now to estimate v
that would just correspond to take my
vector of constants b then the multi
who on the left speak reverse of the
not matrix so I need to reverse
alas I can use the module line
algae in straw that have a method
an imf function that allows to invert
a sum matrix gives innovative
inverted and then of sum stays longer
than to ask the function equips for
multiply linverse by b what will me
give my life estimate so if I
prints them I do get 4 on
So that's because we 4 out of 9 1 and 2
as we had calculated by hand
previously
so that would be the business procedure
are wanted to solve a system
of linear equations but
automatically in this case also with
python and so that's it
the information we need to
execute the iteration algorithm by
policy